>>Matt Mastracci: Hi everyone.
My name is Matt Mastracci.
You're in GWT Linkers.
I am the CTO of Dotspots.
We are a company that uses GWT extensively.
Our product involves a Chrome extension, a
Firefox extension.
We have a website.
All of these things are built using GWT.
And because all of these forms are so different
from each other, we actually make heavy use
of a GWT feature called Linkers.
Okay. So I don't know what the state of the
wireless is right now.
It's been going up and down.
If – is everyone here on wireless?
Do you have access to the Wave?
I'll be taking questions at the mic or on
Wave.
We'll just – we'll see if the network stays
up.
If not, I'll just – I'll take them at the
mic at the end of the presentation.
I/O 2010 dash GWT 4.
Okay.
So let's go over the agenda.
I'm going to start off the talk just briefly
recapping how GWT loads code.
You might have seen this in Joel's talk earlier
today.
They had a similar diagram.
But just in case you haven't been there, we'll
go over it again.
We'll move in to what Linkers are.
We'll talk about artifacts and how artifacts
propagate through Linker chains.
We'll move on to the SelectionScriptLinker
and I'll talk about the Web Worker Linker
from speed tracer.
We're gonna go through a demo where we'll
actually build a linker here.
And depending on how we are doing for time
at the end of the presentation, I'll go over
some advanced linking concepts, developer
guided code splitting, development mode, some
upcoming features you might want to be aware
of.
Okay.
So we're just going to start off talking about
how GWT loads code.
I mentioned before – you may have seen this
in, in Joel's presentation here.
The first step of GWT's code loading process
– we load the host page.
This is the host – the host page is the
page specified in the URL.
It's just a regular HTML file, possibly generated
by your server.
It has a reference to something called the
selection script.
The selection script is a bit of Java script
responsible for determining the current environment
of your GWT applications.
So this is the current browser you're running
in.
This is the – if you're using internationalization
-- which language you're running in.
Possibly any of your personally defined properties
that you might want to switch.
So it determines which permutation of these
properties is running and then it loads the
permutation script.
The permutation script basically contains
all the information required to start your
GWT, your GWT module, start its entry point.
And once this finishes loading, your module
is up and running.
GWT 2.0 introduced something new, though.
I'll talk about this a bit later and how this
relates to Linkers but basically you can add
these RunAsync statements in your GWT code
– you can sprinkle them.
And this will tell your compiler you want,
you want to load the code later on rather
than right away.
If you are running certain kinds of Linkers,
you'll have to be aware of how this code gets
generated so you'll have to put some support
into your Linker to actually make these things
work.
We'll get into that kind of later on in the
talk.
Okay.
So what exactly is a Linker?
The – everybody's deployment story is different.
Just – we have a certain form of web application
at Dotspots.
We use a CDN, we use Amazon CloudFront for
storing all of our static files including
the files we generate in GWT.
So we have a certain layout that we have to
maintain before we do our, before we actually
push out our deployment.
And every one of you here is probably going
to have subtly different requirements in your
deployment.
I mean, they're all going to be very close
to one theme – the standard web application
theme.
But there's going to be subtle differences
everywhere.
You may also have subtle differences in how
you bootstrap your GWT application.
You may, you might want to generate certain
– basically put in certain values into
your Java script global environment.
You might want to pre-generate some data in
just a little blob.
There's tons of little tweaks you might want
to have on your environment.
Now the GWT team, when they, they came up
with the idea of this Linker stack at the
end of the compile, instead of saying, 'Okay.
Let's try to write a bunch of Linkers that
support every one of these use cases out there."
Instead, what they did is they took a step
back; they said, 'Okay. What are the most
common ways you're gonna want to deploy a
web application and let's support these out
of the box. But then let's build a big pluggable
stack that anybody can extend, replace, augment."
Basically, it's something that you can plug
into to customize it, to make it actually
do what you want, something where it doesn't
take a lot of work to do.
So the idea behind the GWT Linker stack is
that it makes GWT really flexible.
So you can now take something that's a Java
to Java script compiler, like the GWT compiler
parts, and then you can take that output Java
script and you can put it wherever you want.
In our case, we take a GWT module; we turn
it into a Firefox extension.
We take a GWT module; we turn it into a Chrome
extension.
We generate our website from another module
We've even got a module that publishers can
just include on their site with just a little
script tag.
So all of these things are generated from
GWT and what we do is we use Linkers to basically
shape how this output looks on disk.
So one thing to note about Linkers is that
every piece of information that ends up on
disk goes through the Linker stack so ultimately
you have full control over what's on disk
at the end of the compile.
Nothing is written that you don't have the
ability to tweak or change or throw away of
you wanted to.
Linkers give you full control.
So I'm just going to quickly talk about the
built-in Linkers of GWT because these are
the things that ship with GWT right away.
You can use these to customize your deployment
story to a small degree.
So the Iframe linker – if you don't do anything
in your module configuration file, this is
the Linker that you'll get.
What this does is that it generates dot-cache-dot-html
files that are loaded from the same domain
as your host page.
Because they live in Iframes – because of
the browser same origin policy – you can't
actually serve these from another domain.
They have to be served from the same domain
as the host page.
So for deployments that require loading scripts
from another place, there's the XS Linker
or the Cross Site Linker.
This generates dot-cache-dot-js files which
are loaded using script tags and because they
use script tags, they're not subject to the
same origin policy and now you can load your
scripts from another domain – say a content
distribution network or you can turn your
GWT application into a gadget in some places.
Finally the last, the last Linker that ships
with GWT here is the SingleScriptLinker.
SingleScriptLinker is a special linker that
basically in-lines one permutation that's
output from the compiler into your selection
script and this, this linker is useful in
a small number of cases where you might be
writing a library that only has one permutation.
You're not really interacting with the browser
dom.
You're just writing something that the CPU
– basically just does some processing.
In this case, the linker will actually fail
if you actually try to pass more than one
permutation to it.
The important thing to remember here is that
each one of these Linkers uses the same linker
stack that you have access to when you are
writing your application.
So if you wanted, you could duplicate the
functionality of these, these Linkers exactly
without having to use any special GWT API's
or special knowledge of how GWT works.
Basically this is, these are just some pre-,
pre-compiled recipes for you that you can
use if you want to.
Okay, so I'm just going to briefly talk about
switching linkers.
If you've ever changed from the Iframe linker
to the CrossSite linker, you'll know what
I'm talking about here.
Just quickly talk about it.
The add-linker declaration in your module
XML file is used for this.
I've got a small example here where I've taken
the default GWT web application.
I've compiled it.
As I mentioned before, I'm not actually specifying
a linker so by default, I get the Iframe linker.
I put in an 'Add-Linker' declaration and now
I get dot-cache-dot-js files.
And what you'll notice is that I'm not actually
getting dot-cache-dot-html files any more.
And the reason is that both XSLlinker and
Iframe linker are primary linkers.
And I'm going to talk a bit more about primary
linkers later and exactly what they are but
there can only be one because they, these
types of linkers control the shape of your
Java script so much that only one can actually
run at any time –it doesn't really make
sense because you're either generating a Firefox
XPI or a Chrome extension – you're not generating
both at the same time.
Okay.
I'm going to move on to artifacts here which
are kind of like a fundamental part of Linkers
and how they work.
So if you, if you're writing GWT code, you
might wonder why you really need to move into
writing Linkers to get your output finalized.
You might be familiar with Ant or Bash, Python,
whatever – all these scripting languages
which you normally use to manipulate files,
to aggregate them, zip them up, et cetera.
The reason you don't want to use Ant to finish
up your deployment is that all of the metadata
about the compile is thrown away at the end
of the compile.
What happens at the end of the compile is
you end up with some raw Java script on disk
and there's no information about where that
Java script came from.
The – you have a hard time telling the Java
script that's compiled for Internet Explorer
from the Java script that's compiled for Firefox.
It's – basically, they just look like Java
script files to you.
You really – you don't have access to all
the rich information that's available in the
compiler after everything's been written to
disk.
An artifact is the answer here.
So an artifact comes from the compile process
but it also contains information about where
it came from.
So basically, an artifact says, 'Okay. I was
compiled for Internet Explorer. I was compiled
for Firefox. I contain the English language
version of the application or the French language'
or other properties.
Artifacts also – depending on the type of
artifact – may contain other information
about which Linker they came from -- any special
information there.
So really an artifact is just a piece of information
passed through the GWT compile process and
then through the linker chain and then finally,
potentially written to disk.
And artifacts are really just Java objects
– the name 'artifact' of course just comes
from the base class that all these artifacts
implement.
Artifacts in your compile – they come from
a number of places.
So your module XML – if you specify script
or style references – those become artifacts
in the compile.
If you use the public path for a module, files
in the module's public path become artifacts.
The compiler generates artifacts after the
compile is done – they're called compilation
results.
The generators that run during the compile
have the opportunity to emit artifacts.
An example of course is the image bundle stuff
that's – you might be using right now.
Those – the generator for the image bundler
emits the PNG files – the bundled PNG files
at the end of the generator run and those
are later found in the application's output.
And another cool thing about generators and
– sorry – artifacts – is that once
you get into writing really advanced linkers
and generators, you can actually start using
artifacts as a way to pass messages from your
generator to your linker because every, every
artifact that your generator creates is passed
down from the compiler through the linker
chain and every linker has a chance to look
at it.
So you can, you can basically create some
information at compile time that uses the
rich type information of the compiler and
then have access to that after the compile
is completed and all that type information
is thrown away – you may still have information
that you may wanna take a look at.
We'll talk a bit about this later – an example
of where this is actually used.
The important thing to note about artifacts
is that they travel around in something called
an ArtifactSet and this isn't anything really
fancy – it's just basically a Java sorted
set that contains artifacts.
The ArtifactSet though has an interesting
set of methods which make it type aware.
You can ask an ArtifactSet to give you all
the artifacts of a given type so you may have
a certain subclass of artifact that you put
in there – you can ask for all artifacts
of that type and all their subclasses.
You can use the ArtifactSet as just a bag
of information that you can query at all these
different points in the compile process or
you may be able to ask for types that GWT
itself has – types of artifacts that GWT
itself has put in there.
So of course, the big example of using this
type where property of ArtifactSets – every
piece of information that ends up on disk
as part of your compile comes from an artifact
that is a subclass of EmittedArtifact.
This is a special base class for an artifact
that just tells GWT that this file is going
to end up on disk and any artifact that isn't
a subclass of this special class is just thrown
away at the end of the compile.
It just kind of disappears, gets garbage collected,
et cetera.
You have to remember if you want it to end
up on disk, create, create a subclass of EmittedArtifact
and your file will then end up at disk, on
disk at the end of the compile process.
An important thing of course to note is that
even if you might not be a subclass of EmittedArtifact,
you can still actually access all these artifacts
all throughout the chain – they're still
available.
You only have to be a subclass of EmittedArtifact
if you want to retain this artifact after
the compile is finished.
So let's just quickly recap this just so it's
clear exactly what artifacts are and how they
flow.
The, the final output of your web application
is basically EmittedArtifacts from the ArtifactSet;
the source code itself generates artifacts
directly from files in the public path; the
compiler when it runs outputs compilation
results into the ArtifactSet; and any generators
that the compiler runs may emit their own
artifacts; and finally, after the compiler
runs the linkers run and linkers both read
and write artifacts and whatever's left basically
at the end of this process is your web application.
Okay.
So, let's actually get into the meat of the
presentation – what linkers are.
Linkers are basically a bunch of code that
you write that runs somewhere inside GWT's
linker chain.
The linker chain is -- it's kind of a fancy
word for just a bunch of linkers that happen
to be run in sequence using the output of
the previous linker.
It's, it's really simple.
You can actually – you can dig through all
the GWT code to see how this works but it's
really just running the linkers in order,
passing the ArtifactSet from linker to linker,
and then writing the output.
Every linker has what's called an order.
It's either pre-, post-, or primary linker
and this just tells GWT where in the linker
chain your linker runs.
The – as you can probably, as you can imagine
from the name – pre-linkers run first, the
primary linker then runs, then all your post-linkers
run and at the end of that post-link is where
your application is written.
Every one of these linkers in this linker
chain – they are connected as I mentioned
before by ArtifactSets – every linker gets
an ArtifactSet as a parameter to its link
method.
It then creates a copy of that ArtifactSet,
makes any changes it needs and then returns
that ArtifactSet where it's then passed on
to the next linker.
It's, it's fairly straightforward – just
a bunch of ArtifactSets getting passed around.
The linker that runs in the primary order
is basically the most important linker that
runs during the GWT compile process.
It's really ultimately responsible for how
the application looks at the end of the compile
– like the general idea – sorry – the
general layout of the application -- so small
differences between cross-site and the Iframe
linker versus –maybe your application is
ending up as a Firefox extension zipped up
or a Chrome extension zipped up.
These big differences – they basically come
from the choice of primary linker.
The primary linker's responsible for a number
of things.
The primary linker is basically responsible
for bootstrapping your GWT application which
means figuring out the correct permutations,
loading – loading whatever permutation is
active, et cetera.
They control the deferred fragment loading
as well so they –
Writing a primary linker is definitely a much
bigger job than writing the pre- or post-
linkers – I'll just mention those in a couple
seconds here.
So a couple of examples of primary linkers.
The Iframe and cross-site linkers – all
the GWT built-in ones you may be familiar
with.
The browser extension linkers.
Speed Tracer has actually written the, the
best primary linkers that you can actually
take a look at right now today.
They actually have an HTML5 Web Worker Linker
which I am going to talk about in a little
more detail in a few minutes here.
This is actually available in the Speed Tracer
source code so you can take a look at this
during or after the talk and see how it actually
works and play with it if you wanted to.
And as well, the Speed Tracer team actually
has a Chrome extension linker in there.
They -- it's rolled into the Speed Tracer
source but it's, it's something you can use
if you wanted to – if you wanted to compile
your own web modules to Chrome extensions.
If you are writing a primary linker, I mentioned
that primary linkers are responsible for so
much – you, when you write a primary linker,
you are actually responsible for making sure
that you keep track of changes to how GWT
actually bootstraps its modules internally.
The—if you are writing primary linkers,
this is – it's kind of a big responsibility
because the way that the compiler generates
this Java script changes subtly from version
to version.
It may have new requirements for variables
that you have to provide before your GWT module
is bootstrapped.
There's a – you actually have to get your
module up and running.
These are all things you're going to have
to keep track of – and you'll want to keep
an eye on the release notes of GWT from version
to version just to make sure that nothing
major has changed.
It's – small changes will come down from
time to time so if a new version of GWT comes
out, you'll definitely want to be testing
right away because it's possible that something
may have changed.
Just an example – there's something called
'Soft Permutations' which I'll talk about
later in the talk.
This is going to be coming down in a future
GWT version.
I'm not actually sure what the plan is for
it but if you are running a primary linker,
this will actually change how your primary
linker has to work so someone keep an eye
on it.
Pre-order linkers – they run before the
primary linker so they actually have a chance
to take a look at all the artifacts before
the primary linker gets them.
They can potentially modify these artifacts,
swap them out for something else.
They're also a really good place –as I mentioned
early in the presentation, you can, you can
send messages from the generators that run
during the compile to linkers that run after
the compile.
If you're writing a pre-order linker, this
is the best place for you to actually examine
those messages that you sent from your generator
and turn them into something concrete that's
emitted to disk at the end of the compile.
An example here -- GWT actually has something
called an RpcPolicyManifestLinker.
This is a special internal linker in GWT that
takes a look at all the remote services that
you've implemented in your code and it, it
generates a serialization white list from
it.
The – what happens is every time you create
a remote service in your code, one of these
RpcPolicyFileArtifacts is emitted into the
ArtifactSet.
This, this isn't actually an EmittedArtifact
that ends up on disk.
This is just a piece of information that sits
in, sits in this ArtifactSet until the linker's
run.
And then when the linker runs after the compile's
done, it takes a look and can see all the
types that are used in serialization, turns
them into a file which you put on the server
and that file will then white list all the
types used for all of the remote services
in your web application.
And then, finally of course, there's the post-order
linkers.
These run after the primary linkers so you
have a chance to take a look at every file
that's been generated by the primary linker,
make changes there.
It, it is important to note that if you, if
you don't really want to maintain a primary
linker, you might have some subtle differences
in how you want your web application to work
from a primary linker.
You could actually – instead of writing
a full primary linker, just write a post-ordered
linker that is responsible for tweaking the
output of that primary linker just enough
to actually make it work for your situation.
So this way, it's the primary ordered linker's
job to keep up with GWT changes but you can
just tweak it and tweak your deployment the
way you want it – renaming files or moving
files around.
If it's just a subtle change, you probably
will just want to write a post-order linker.
One example, of course, of a post-order linker
is the off line application Manifest Linker
-- we'll talk about that in a demo in a few
minutes here.
We'll actually build this one from scratch.
Okay.
So SelectionScriptLinker is something you're
gonna need to know if you ever actually start
writing a primary linker.
This is most likely gonna be the subclass
that you're gonna use.
Because there are so many things you're responsible
for if you were writing a primary linker,
the GWT team wrote SelectionScriptLinker as
something that does all the heavy lifting
for you.
Every primary linker basically has to do the
same things.
It has to deal with bootstrapping, your GWT
module; it has to deal with determining the
current permutation you're running; it has
to deal with this developer guided code splitting.
SelectionScriptLinker is something already
written for you that understands all these
things that has to be done and can do them
for most primary linkers.
It just needs a little bit of additional input
to tell it how to work.
And I'm gonna explain it a little more in
detail using the Web Worker Linker.
The Web Worker Linker is a primary linker
that the Speed Tracer team wrote.
It is a subclass of SelectionScriptLinker,
as you'd expect.
And just a quick summary of what it does – it
takes a GWT module and lets you load it as
an HTML5 Web Worker.
So by saying 'web worker' and the name of
your module, you, you basically bring up another
thread running your GWT module in the browser
– like a virtual browser thread.
It's actually so simple I've in-lined it into
my slides here.
This dedicated Web Worker Linker is – it's
actually amazing that the linker stack is
so powerful that you can create a Web Worker
Linker in so few lines of code.
And you'll see – I've got one more slide
but the amount of code actually required here
is pretty miniscule.
There are 5 methods that this linker implements.
And none of these methods are actually that
complicated.
The getDescription is of course required by
all linkers.
It's just a human readable string of what
your linker is.
The next 4 methods are actually – the methods
I talked about before that are required for
you to implement if you were a subclass of
SelectionScriptLinker.
getCompilationExtension just tells SelectionScriptLinker
what the file extension should be for the
permutations it generates.
getModulePrefix and Suffix are methods that
tell the SelectionScriptLinker what the Java
script – it should put above and below the
generated Java script from your Java code.
The compiler, when it runs, outputs something
called a compilation result.
It's a special type of artifact which is,
basically, raw Java script, the raw Java script
equivalent of the Java code you put in it.
But it's missing all the important information
needed to bootstrap it.
It's just the raw information, the raw code
for your web app.
Now ModulePrefix and Suffix let you actually
surround that with whatever you need to bootstrap
this application.
You may have special global variables that
are important.
You might have –you may want to wrap it
in a Java script function so you don't pollute
the global name space when you load your module
– things like that.
But in this case, the Web Worker Linker – because
it's running in its own isolated sandbox,
it just – it returns empty strings here.
It writes the Java script naked to disk and
loads that directly.
Finally the last method here is getSelectionScriptTemplate.
This just tells SelectionScriptLinker the
name of a Java resource that it's going to
use to create your selection script.
This is just a standard Java resource that
lives next to your class file – in this
case, DedicatedWorkerTemplate.js which I've
got on the next slide here.
The, the selection script template, SelectionScriptLinker
basically takes a selection script template
and turns it into your, your module selection
script effectively.
It, the template contains the number of places
that are used to customize – sorry -- the
SelectionScriptLinker will actually replace
these special place holders with the appropriate
module functions.
So in this case here, you can see there's
a number of placeholders – first one is
MODULE_FUNC – this is just a Java script
compatible version of your module name.
PERMUTATIONS_BEGIN and _END are just block
markers that tell SelectionScriptLinker where
to, where to start in replacing the selection
script logic, et cetera.
The, the Permutation logic is actually where
the selection script is gonna figure out which
browser it's running on and which language
is currently selected.
So what happens in the permutation logic is
a number of browser checks.
It'll check the user agent to see if it's
running on Firefox, it's running on Webkit
–it'll run any other property checks that
it might have, and at the end of the permutation
logic, the – at the very top you can see
the variable name 'strongName'.
That variable 'strongName' will be populated
with the strong name of the permutation that
should run given all these properties that
have been detected in this permutation logic.
So then the 'strongName' is passed into the
import scripts function.
Import scripts has a, is a special function
in the web worker context.
What this does is it loads the file, the script
file that you referenced from the network
or from file et cetera and it'll block the
web worker until that script is actually loaded,
initialized and then returned.
So at this point, our permutation is loaded.
We then call gwtOnLoad – 'G-W-T OnLoad'.
This is a special function that the G-W-T
compiler specifies that actually bootstraps
your GWT application.
This is part of the compilation result that
the compiler output.
As soon as you call this function, this effectively
calls into the entry point of your module.
This gwtOnLoad – you call it and your GWT
module is up and running.
So, as I mentioned before, this is such a
simple linker.
Just these few dozen lines of code are enough,
basically, to turn a GWT module into a full
HTML5 Web Worker.
And most primary linkers – even though it
does sound ominous – there is a lot of stuff
you're responsible for – in the end most
of these GWT linkers are actually fairly simple.
They – a lot of – in the cases where you
are responsible for a lot of things, the GWT
team has actually provided a lot of interesting
classes that do a lot of the work for you
so you don't even have to – in the end,
you're only writing a few lines of code anyways.
You should be taking a look at Iframe linker
and access linker in the GWT source too if
you are interested in writing primary linkers.
Those will kind of go through what other responsibilities
you have as a primary order linker just to
give you an idea of what you need to do.
Okay, so this is the exciting part where we
actually build a linker.
Just a bit of background about this demo we're
actually gonna run here.
The – HTML 5 specifies something called
an Offline Manifest.
An Offline Manifest allows your HTML 5 application
to run without a network connection.
So you specify manifest.
The browser is now responsible for grabbing
files in this manifest, making sure that they're
available while the browser's offline and
then, when you hit this, hit this website
and there is no network connection available,
the browser then goes to the manifest rather
than the network to pull your application
up.
And I'm not going to go through the entire
specification.
You can grab it off the W3 site.
They have an offline web app specification
you can look at.
You, you specify that your web app is offline
capable by adding a manifest attribute to
your HTML element.
And the manifest itself, again, is very straightforward.
You add a cache manifest header, then you
list out all the files you want to be available
offline for your application.
It's, it's pretty straightforward.
It's just a very simple file listing the files
that need to be available.
So let me actually switch over to Eclipse
here.
[pause]
Okay.
So in Eclipse here, I've just got the standard
GWT sample application that you can create
yourself – just a very simple demo that
has a button, connects to a network service,
et cetera.
What we want, we want is a -- we want to create
an Offline Manifest for this web application
so that when the user's not connected, they
can still run our app.
The first thing we're gonna do, of course
– we have to open up our host page and
we're going to add this manifest.
I've already added here just to save some
time
We say 'HTML manifest equals Linker Demo Offline
Manifest'.
Linker demo of course is this directory here.
This directory is just the output directory
of my web application.
So we want to generate a file named 'offline
dot manifest' that's output in the standard
GWT application output directory at the end
of the compile to make this application offline
capable.
Okay, so why don't we start?
Before I start, I'm just going to reduce the
number of permutations I have to compile because
when you're writing a linker, you actually
want to debug the GWT compiler.
The – if you, if you've been compiling your
GWT application using the compile project
button in Eclipse, this runs your – this
fires up a JVM and runs a compile but it doesn't
actually run it in debug mode.
What you can do though because the GWT compiler
is written in Java, you can actually create
your own launch target to debug the Java compiler.
So before – let me just quickly do this.
I'm gonna set property – name equals user
agent – value equals safari.
So I'm just reducing the number of permutations
we're gonna compile.
Just cause this is a demo, I'm going to rapidly
iterate, compile as quick as possible.
I'm gonna create a new launch target.
Okay, so we create a new Java application
launch target.
I'm gonna call it 'compiler'.
And I pick the project that we've got.
The main class is actually going to be the
GWT – G-W-T compiler.
So we're going to, we're actually gonna debug
the compiler here.
So under program arguments, another thing
that's useful when you're gen – when you're
writing your own linkers – there's a flag
you can pass – draft compile and this just
reduces the amount of optimization that happens
during the GWT compile process.
So cuts a few seconds off and this of course
is really useful when you're writing something
that happens after the GWT compile.
And of course, the next argument to the compiler
is always the module you're compiling and
– just so I don't mess this up – it's
'com Google I O linker demo dot linker demo'.
Finally, because GWT actually resolves the
Java files that it compiles from your class
path, we actually have to add the source directory
of our project as a folder on the class path
[pause]
Before we can successfully compile.
Okay.
So let me just hit the debug button and just
make sure I got all this stuff right here.
Okay, so while this waits – sorry, while
this is compiling, we'll just leave this running.
Let's actually start writing our linker.
Okay.
So I'm gonna call our linker the 'offline
' oops – the 'offline linker' and it's
going to live in the 'com Google I O linker
dem' – oops – 'Google I O linker demo
dot linker package'.
Okay.
Our compile succeeded in the background there.
And you'll actually see that after I added
that set property, I'm only getting one permutation
compiled and it took significantly less time
to compile.
So, okay, so the offline linker that we're
writing, the Offline Manifest requires the
name of all of the files in the output of
your web application.
This thing is going to have to run after the
primary linker so we can actually see what
files were generated.
We're going to set the order of this linker
then to 'post'.
All right.
So the base class of our off line linker – every
linker that you create in GWT has to be a
subclass of linker basically an abstract class
that GWT has defined.
But there is actually another subclass of
linker called abstractlinker and abstractlinker
is just – it's basically linker with a few
extra helper methods that are useful if you're
emitting artifacts that end up in your web
app.
So if you are writing something like this,
you'll probably just want to subclass abstractlinker.
Then you get access to these helper methods
which we'll be using in a few minutes here.
So 'extend abstract linker'.
Okay, let's just add the unimplemented methods.
I mentioned before 'getDescription' is just
a human readable string.
We're going to call this the 'HTML 5 Offline
Linker' and the link method, of course, is
the most important method.
This is, this is what runs during the linker
chain of the GWT compile.
The – you can see here, I mentioned before,
the linker chain is constructed by passing
the output of one linker to the input of another
linker.
This is the, this is the input here – artifacts.
We're going to create a new ArtifactSet from
that.
Now it's important to note that the ArtifactSet
passed into your linker is actually immutable.
You actually can't make changes to it.
You have to create a brand new ArtifactSet
every time.
So we're going to create a new ArtifactSet
from it.
Oops.
[pause]
'From artifacts'
And I'm just going to return that from the
linker directly.
And what I've done here is actually create
a pass through linker.
This is kind of the simplest example of a
no op linker.
It runs.
It takes input from the previous linker, passes
it out, and that's it.
It's just a very simple no op linker.
Before we actually flesh this out, let's do
some, let's do some GWT bookkeeping and actually
define our linker and tell G-W-T that we want
to use this linker during the compile.
So we have to add a new attribute – define
linker.
We have to tell G-W-T which linker we're going
to be defining so I'm just copying the full
name – oops.
'Full name'.
And I'm gonna name it the 'Offline Linker'.
Okay so this name here is the same name that
you use in your 'Add linker' directive.
'Head linker name equals Offline'.
You can, you can actually define linkers without
using them.
This of course is useful – you might have
a utility linker in a library.
You may not – it might be optional for people
to use.
They'll actually have to use 'add linker'
before that linker is active.
Okay, so let's, let's set a breakpoint in
the offline linker.
And let's fire up the compiler here.
[pause]
Okay.
So this is gonna take a few seconds to get
to our breakpoint.
Okay.
So of course linkers run after the compiler
so we’re just waiting for the compiler to
spit out the compilation results so we can
take a look at them.
This is going to take a few seconds here.
Thankfully we only have one permutation so
we're not waiting too long.
Okay, there we go.
So I've actually set a breakpoint in the GWT
compiler at the point where it's invoking
my linker.
You can see here the stack trace is full of
GWT code, compiler, the link, standard linking
contacts and finally, the offline linker.
Now, if I take a quick look at this ArtifactSet
that's actually been generated – sorry,
the ArtifactSet that's passed in, you can
see it's full of basically all the different
artifacts that come out of GWT.
Ooops.
Some – you'll see some files here that came
from module public paths, you'll see the compilation
results, you'll see the HTML files that were
generated by – sorry, the dot cache dot
HTML files that were generated by the Iframe
linker – things like that.
Okay so let's start actually building our
Offline Manifest.
If you recall, the Offline Manifest basically
starts with 'CACHE MANIFEST' followed by a
new line.
And now we actually have to fill this, this
manifest with the files that are available
in the output of the web app.
So let's take, let's iterate over all the
EmittedArtifacts in the input ArtifactSet.
So 'define method' is just a way to query
the ArtifactSet.
'EmittedArtifact'
Okay.
So we're just looping over all these artifacts
that the compiler will be emitting.
Now they're – I'm just adding a check here
for a flag 'is private'.
This is something I didn't mention before
but an EmittedArtifact can be private.
This just means that this artifact, while
it's emitted, is not actually part of your
web application.
This is private developer data that isn't
deployed as part of your application.
So if the artifact is private, we're just
going to continue.
Otherwise, we're going to add it to our manifest.
We're going to emit the partial path.
Partial path is basically just the relative
path of an artifact within your web apps application
directory.
And finally, we'll append a new line.
So thankfully we're running in Eclipse so
as soon as I save that, I can actually just
continue and Eclipse will pick up that new
code.
So there you go.
You can see that I am generating now this
manifest – basically I've got this string
in memory that represents this manifest that
we're gonna write to disk.
So we actually have to emit this now to disk
because if I don't emit this, it's just going
to get lost at the end of the compile.
So we can create a new EmittedArtifact and
let's call it 'manifest'.
And I was mentioning before that AbstractLinker
had a bunch of helper classes that help you
to emit artifacts.
One of the helpers is 'emit string'.
'Emit string' basically takes a string that
you pass it and turns it into a file on disk.
So the parameter 'what' is our manifest – let's
get it from our string builder.
And the file name is going to be 'offline
dot manifest'.
Okay and this is actually just an EmittedArtifact.
This artifact isn't actually linked to anything.
Before we can actually create it on disk,
we have to add it to our ArtifactSet.
So let's, we add it to our ArtifactSet and
now when this method returns, it's going to
be in the output ArtifactSet and G-W-T is
going to see it and write it to disk.
So I'm going to run the code to the end here.
Unfortunately, the ArtifactSet is too big
so it's fairly hard to find it.
Just gonna complete the compilation.
Gonna go down here to the linker demo and
you can see the file we just created in that
linker -- offline dot manifest -- is there.
And the contents of the file are basically
what we put into the string.
So – you can see here – to write any sort
of linker is really just a matter of a few
lines of code.
And it does seem really daunting to write
a linker but in the end, doing almost anything
in the linker is – it just comes down to
some simple manipulation of artifacts and
emitting artifacts in the right place.
So the Web Worker Linker is really simple.
I mean this HTML 5 Offline Linker is extremely
simple.
The Firefox extension linker that we wrote
for Dotspots – it's pretty simple overall.
It's not a lot of work to do this sort of
thing and it's definitely, definitely something
you should look into if you have to do any
sort of customization of your web app.
Okay so I'm not gonna – I'm just gonna kind
of leave the demo there because I can demonstrate
a web app running offline but it's not entirely
exciting.
Let's just – we can move on to the last
few advanced notes here since we've got a
little bit of time.
Okay so some Advanced Linker notes.
I'm not going to deep dive into any of this
stuff.
If you have any questions, I guess we can
kind of visit them after the discussion or
you can always visit them on the GWT users
group where there's, the GWT developers are
available – things like that.
Okay, I'm going to talk briefly here about
developer guided code splitting.
You've probably seen this in a number of talks
already.
The compiler splits fragments across GWT RunAsync
calls.
What you may not have seen in those presentations
is that in web mode, the RunAsync call is
basically delegated to something called a
loading strategy.
And these loading strategies are basically
just a way for you to load the deferred fragments.
So however you're – wherever you put your
deferred fragments, you just need a loading
strategy that's able to bring those back.
There is a default loading strategy – XHR
loading strategy – source is available in
AsyncFragmentLoader if you're interested and
this XHR loading strategy – it's actually
a bit of a misnomer because it actually handles
more than just XML HTTP requests.
It can actually delegate back to you to do
your own requests.
I recommend taking a look at this class and
just seeing how it works.
The contract is actually very simple if you
need to do it – if you need to do any sort
of deferred fragment loading.
So if you're writing a primary linker and
you need to load deferred fragments, take
a look here in AsyncFragmentLoader – the
information should be available.
Development mode is new in GWT 2.0.
The development mode is fairly difficult to
support if you're writing a primary linker.
It's not impossible.
We do actually support it in our Firefox linker.
We had to do a fair bit of work and it's not,
it's not something trivial to support.
If you writing a pre- or post-linker though,
it's not the primary linker's job to deal
with development mode so you definitely can
– you don't really have to worry too much
about supporting it.
It's fairly simple.
The real differences are basically that a
re-link method is also a called linker linker
as well as a link method.
You can – your best bet for this is just
to kind of try it out and when you run into
problems, just come onto the GWT user list
or contributors' list and just ask questions
there because the people who are knowledge,
knowledgeable about this sort of linker are
always there to answer questions.
And of course some upcoming linker features
– in an upcoming version of GWT, your linkers
will be shardable and able to distribute in
your distributable compiles.
I don't know how many of you out there are
actually distributing your GWT compiles to
speed them up but your linkers will basically
be able to participate in this as well.
And soft permutations which are actually pretty
exciting – I don't know when they're gonna
ship but basically this is – Bruce is shrugging
over there.
But it's – basically what this is going
to do – instead of having a hard permutation
– like one permutation file per combination
of properties, you can actually ship multiple
combinations of properties inside a single
file and switch between them at run time.
So if your permutations aren't that different,
instead of generating 2 files which are 99%
the same, you just ship one file and you pay
a small run time cost to switch between them.
And this is only really applicable if you're
writing a primary linker as well.
This is going to change the bootstrap sequence
for a GWT module and again, keep an eye on
the release notes, user group definitely if
you have any questions.
Okay.
So just wrapping this up quickly so we can
leave some time for questions.
Linkers package, analyze, decorate your compiled
scripts.
They give you a much more structured approach
to your output versus Ant scripts or shell
scripts.
They are really easy to write.
They might look daunting but once you get
into it, the concepts are simple.
It's simple to write them.
I hope I've given you enough information from
this talk to go in and write your first linker
in a few minutes.
And basically they make GWT more powerful
than just a simple web application compiler.
It's now a Firefox extension compiler, a Chrome
extension compiler, a Web Worker Linker compiler,
a Google gadget compiler.
It could be an OSX dashboard gadget compiler.
It just adds power to GWT.
I've got a link to the user discussion group
here and I think it'll be in the Wave as well
– and a presentation on the web afterwards.
So I don't know if the network has stayed
up during the whole presentation.
I can head over to the Wave here.
If you have any questions, I guess just step
up to the mike and we can go through as many
as we can, as we have time.
[pause]
Oops.
Sure.
Go ahead.
>>Male audience member #1: Is there any documentation
for this?
>>Matt: I believe the linker documentation
is all in Java doc.
It's – I don't believe that there are currently
specific documents written that go through
linkers and everything you – basically start
from the Java doc for the linker class in
GWT and work your way up from there unfortunately.
That – I can look this up a little bit more.
I can put some more information into the Wave
if I find any.
But as far as I know, I believe it's just
in the Java doc.
Go ahead.
>>Male audience member #2: In the example
of the manifest linker, at one point – 'cause
it's a pass through linker -- you take the
artifact in and you construct a new artifact
and return that.
So the artifacts are immutable.
Is it necessary to, to construct a new one
and if so, why?
>>Matt: It is necessary to create a new ArtifactSet
because – you can actually take a look at
the ArtifactSet source code but the ArtifactSet
passed into your linker is frozen and all
of the mutation methods will basically throw
an exception.
So if you called add on the ArtifactSet, it
would throw – so you just create a new artifact
exception.
The reason for that is actually – it makes
the linker stack a little more flexible for
the GWT team.
They can make some changes in the future that
they couldn't if the ArtifactSets were mutable
so it's – it's not really hard to work around
so they just made them immutable so in the
future, they may take advantage of it and
not actually have to break everybody's linkers
at the time.
I did notice that there is one question in
the Wave here.
I think this is actually out of scope, unfortunately,
for this presentation.
GWT and WebSockets.
The, this might be something you probably
would want to bring up on the user group and
I actually don't know what the GWT plan is
for WebSockets at this time.
Go ahead sir.
>>Male audience member#3: Yes.
Hi.
The artifacts list was basically a list of
the files, right?
So if we wanted to gain access to functions
in those files or things that were declared
in the source code, is there a way to get
to that information provided we know that
the GWT compiler has changed all that – has
done its optimization work?
>>Matt: Okay.
So that's a good question.
The question is basically do we have access
to the type system – basically the dom of
your program in memory after the compile finishes.
The answer to that is unfortunately no.
The – but you can write a generator that
runs at GWT time which has access to some
of the type and member information.
I don't believe – there is no real public
API for the compiler right now like at the
statement expression level but there is – if
you write a generator, you have access to
the type hierarchy, all the methods, the return
types, generics, things like that.
So what you'll probably want to do is write
a generator and pass that information into
your linker if you need that.
Unfortunately, if you need source level information,
that's just not available.
Go ahead.
>>Male audience member #4: Thanks for your
talk.
You mentioned several times your Firefox extension
link.
Is that something Dotspots gonna make available?
>>Matt: I'm – actually that is available.
You can grab that – I believe it's GWT Firefox
extension on Google code and there's an example
extension there if you wanted to play with
it.
I haven't tested this with the latest releases
of GWT but you can grab this, compile it and
you should be able to get an extension up
and running.
You can – there's a Dotspots open source
link on here if you have any questions about
that.
And I can definitely help you through that
if you want to play around with it.
>>Male audience member #4: Thank you very
much.
>>Matt: Thanks.
Okay.
That's pretty much all the time I have.
Thanks a lot for coming.
[applause]